it was a long time coming but mortal
kombat the 2021 reimagining of the
classic fighting game series has been
well worth the wait
the movie's final act is full of setup
paving the way for stories to come
we're here to unpack all of it but
choosing cole young as the central
character the 2021 mortal kombat movie
gives viewers an opportunity to view the
vast mythology of the story and the
games that inspired it in a new way
because cole is portrayed from the start
as a born underdog he's famously good at
taking a punch and while that ability
has never served him all that well in
his normal life once his arcana is
activated it becomes a superpower
the significance of coal's power goes
beyond the mere metaphor of the kinetic
armor that comes with it though
as the last descendant of an ancient
bloodline thought to have been destroyed
he is the living embodiment of human
perseverance
he's a man who will not be kept down
even in the face of a near immortal
ninja monster
it's a powerful statement that forms the
heart of the film particularly when we
consider cole's life as a family man but
our backs are to the wall human beings
do not give up
because cole is an original character
not reflected in any of the mortal
kombat games this message not only hits
home with more resonance but also
provides a solid foundation on which the
film can build out into a whole
franchise
it is fundamentally the story of an
ordinary guy proving that he can use an
unshakable spirit to literally save
the world cole is an ordinary guy who
finds that his particular skills serve
him well in extraordinary circumstances
in contrast his earthrealm comrades
sonja and jax are introduced in the 2021
mortal kombat movie as extraordinary
people who spend the whole film proving
they belong
cole is reluctant to embrace the danger
of the mortal kombat tournament but
sonia and jax have spent years preparing
for it desperate not just to understand
the fight but to make sure it's won
then they're thrown into the deep end as
outworld closes in and both have to
prove they deserve to be there
for jax that means a journey back from
the brink of death a battle against his
own spirit to unlock his arcana and
prove that his strength is about more
than just physical prowess
jax ends the film with super-powered
cybernetic arms but he would never have
gotten there if his courage hadn't
overcome
every obstacle then there's sonja the
champion who never got the mark of a
champion but wants to be part of the
fight anyway because she feels a duty to
those she's lost
in the end by defeating kano she earns
that mark proves she's meant to be there
and becomes a powerful
asset in the fight that's still to come
these two warriors start this particular
journey from a place of extraordinary
courage and insight and they push beyond
that to end the journey as legends
for most of the champions of earthrealm
this mortal kombat story is essentially
about coming to grips with a fight
they've been thrust into
for raiden and luke kang who've been in
the fight for a very long time it's a
journey to trusting in humanity again
and making sacrifices along the way
lord raiden has been a part of the war
between realm since time immemorial
and it's clear from his position early
on in the film that he's lost his way a
bit
he's sick of struggling sick of losing
and sick of the underhanded tactics used
by shang tsung and the outworld
champions but he doesn't seem to know if
he can ever overcome any of that
raiden is brought low and nearly
defeated and his eventual victory comes
not from his own trust in the traditions
of the tournament
but from trusting in his new earth realm
champions because of that by the end of
the film he is filled with hope
likewise lou kang takes a similar
journey from desperation to hope
the bright flame wielding warrior
clearly always wanted to lead the charge
for earth realm with his adopted brother
kong lao his side but in one of the
film's most emotional scenes
kung lao is taken out of the fight liu
kang is left then to fight alongside
virtual strangers
by the end he considers them brothers
and sisters in arms and is able to face
the future as a happy warrior once again
for most immortal combat chong soon is
as confident as raiden is desperate the
sorcerer from outworld spends much of
the film with a comfortable nine
straight tournament victories to his
realm's name
a squad of terrifying champions at his
back and seemingly the deadliest
champion in any realm sub-zero in his
corner so naturally we get to watch him
spend most of the film making
overcompetent choice after
over-confident choice and paying the
price
he underestimates the new champions of
earth realm as well as the resolve of
the existing ones
he thinks that raiden's reliance on
tradition and rules means that he will
never be able to win another tournament
he believes that humans are weak not
just in body but in spirit
and while he's proven right in kano's
case he's wrong about the others
he even believes that killing kung lao
will break earth realm rather than
merely strengthening their resolve
shong soon is ultimately proven wrong
about all of these things but seems to
learn the wrong lessons each and every
time
by the end of the film he's promising
raiden that he'll return not just with
more champions but with
armies from outworld ready to invade
earthrealm mortal kombat is about more
than might but shang soon still doesn't
understand that
though we spend most of the film's run
time following cole young's journey the
emotional backbone of mortal kombat is
also formed by the journey of his
ancestor hanzo asashi who returns from
the climactic battle in the form of the
nether realm assassin known as scorpion
asashi like his descendant cole is
someone whose entire emotional core came
from his family
and whose grief was so profound at
losing them in the film's prologue that
he's descended into hell and plotted his
eventual revenge across centuries
when he re-emerges as scorpion asashi is
every bit the spirit of vengeance
showing no mercy in his battle against
sub-zero but he has not become a
heartless monster
his sense of family remains strong as he
helps cole to free his own wife and
child
and then entrusts him with continuing
the hasashi bloodline proving that
centuries in nether realm have not
stripped him of all of his humanity
scorpion also ends his presence in the
film by telling cole that he's freed him
he disappears but the film doesn't tell
us where he's gone he's no longer bound
by vengeance so is it possible that he
doesn't have to return to netherrealm
can he be at peace
can he still return for future battles
if cole needs him these are questions
ripe for exploration in a sequel film
even as marketing materials for mortal
kombat began to roll out
and introduce the world to lewis tan as
cole young fans were suspecting some
hidden reveal waiting in the film
theories emerged that tan was actually
playing a version of one of the
franchise's most famous earth realm
characters johnny cage
of course the film eventually proved all
those theories wrong
cole young is exactly who he says he is
an entirely new character descended from
hanzo asashi but that doesn't mean
there's no johnny cage in the film
the character finally makes an
appearance via a movie poster in the
final shot
as cole heads out to hollywood to
seemingly recruit cage to be a champion
for earthrealm in the film's sequel
this is of course a moment worth
celebrating for longtime mortal kombat
fans but also sets the stage for a
number of different future relationships
how will cage and cole get along will
cage and sonja connect romantically and
have a daughter like they did in the
mortal kombat games
there's so much to consider based on
that final shot alone and it makes this
franchise an exciting thing for longtime
fans to dream about
though we don't really get to spend any
time with them in the film both lord
raiden and chong soon frequently
reference the elder gods throughout
mortal kombat
these are as the film implies the
all-powerful beings who created the
various realms
and thus the stage on which the endless
mortal kombat tournament plays out they
may not make an appearance in the film
but their presence is keenly felt
particularly in the ways both raiden and
shang soon view them for much of the
film raiden presents the elder gods as
an ultimate authority who are to be
revered respected and obeyed as they
have been for millennia while xiang soon
sees them as outdated relics of a bygone
age he hopes to overthrow via an
invasion of earth realm and by extension
eventually all of the other realms as
well shong soon spits in the face of the
mortal kombat traditions while raiden
tries to honor them
eventually through cole's plan to bring
the tournament fight to outworlds
champions via raiden's powers the elder
gods are presented with a kind of hybrid
of both views
the tournament still happens but it
happens through bending the rules
how the elder gods respond to that if
they respond at all
will they try to stop shang soon's
outright invasion even if we don't see
them in the sequel we'll almost
certainly hear about their reaction
with the exception of a few notable
flashes to scorpion's development in the
nether realm the 2021 mortal kombat
movie takes place pretty much entirely
in two realms
earth realm which is just our world with
a bunch of superpower champions hidden
in it
and the desolate harsh landscape of
outworld where shang soon tries to
launch his invasion
these realms are more than enough to
move the engine of the plot to the first
film but mortal kombat gamers know
they're far from the only places to
explore in the lore of the franchise
we have no idea yet if we're even
getting a mortal kombat sequel
let alone if the sequel will actually
explore other realms but there's plenty
more to explore there
for instance the realm of adenia which
as its name suggests
is eden-like was also once on the end of
an outworld losing streak and had to
actually fight back against a full-scale
invasion from outworld
then there's the order realm and chaos
realm which are pretty self-explanatory
in terms of what they're respectively
into
these realms are at each other's throats
thanks to differing philosophies
and of course there's more than another
realm to explore including the possible
returns of key characters who died
fighting in the first film only to end
up there as revenants
it's a big universe and any mortal
kombat follow-up can take full advantage
of that
the mortal kombat reboot is a film that
spends its entire run time walking the
line between paying tribute to the
mythos of the games that came before it
and breaking new ground in the way the
franchise lore
works that means it's able to explore
various elements of the series in new
ways and one of the most potent of these
is the revelation that under the right
circumstances
anyone can be a champion kind of wins
the film introduces the concept of the
dragon mark to mortal kombat
and through cole's perspective reveals
both what that means and how it leads to
the eventual unlocking of one's power
through some kind of emotional
experience
cole's journey from underdog fighter to
champion as he realizes his family is
the key to his arcana is a testament to
human perseverance but sonia's journey
is arguably just as important
rather than being chosen for the
tournament like cole she takes her place
by killing kano and earning his dragon
mark
thus proving that with enough heart
determination anyone can both be chosen
for the tournament and earn some arcana
of their very own
that means that future films in the
franchise could introduce even more
entirely new characters who make their
way into this world simply by defeating
the right bad guy or scamming the right
good guy
it could be pun intended a game changer
for the series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite
stop for coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one